香蕉有沒有開戶
我有開戶
在疫情的那一陣子
航運三雄
剛沖起來一直沖
以前都很低迷的時候
他沖到百元的時候
就趁那個時候開戶了
因為朋友也一直有聲音說
他有賺錢就進去了
當股市小白
那是你人生第一次買股票是嗎
第一次買股票
我買的時候其實有一點點
你買航運三雄
航運三雄
一開始有一點成就感
航運三雄就買零股
因為太貴了
我還有買那個聯電啊
很多 他們都會相信作業
40多塊買 50多塊賣
他就跌下來 40多塊又買
50多塊又賣
賺1000多 賺2000多 賺1000多
我等於每天都有賺一點點
賺一點點 很快樂
賺了十幾萬 二十幾萬
後來康君參選
我就是有買 也賣
有買 也賣
都一張一張一張的了
每天差價 他有時候漲停
隔天又跌停
我都有抓到價差
可是電話打來了
問我說要不要開當充
對
我說當初什麼意思
他說當天就可以買也可以賣了
我說也不錯
我就買
有時候我就一天賣兩張
那這樣不就是兩倍嗎
照我原本的操作
後來他有一次是連續三根下去
跌停了
我全部都
萬海 陽明 長榮
都各兩張在裡面
等於有100多萬在裡面
我全部下去
瞬間帳面變富80幾萬
哇
太痛了 80幾萬是你要做多久的收入
對 我就在想我的本業
我一直做 甚至還有時候還沒工作的話
你這樣子嘴巴弄到壞掉都沒有辦法
嘴巴麻掉也賺不到零頭
動詞動詞
對 逼到
大家都膩了
還是沒電
你再表演一段
看他 你就做那個多辛苦
大家好
我不當
衝
你們不攔
陪死
所以我現在比較二十了
這個很棒
不不不
現在你要弄到左久才八十幾
這個弄到嘴巴抽筋都沒辦法
這個賺得還不到虧損的零頭
我後來其實手麻腳麻
我也不敢賣
因為賣了就代表任力
我是真正損失
那不是紙上的貧窮
對
原來那都是紙上富貴
我就真的賣了
因為我很怕第四跟第五根
一直下去
對
我賣掉之後
我想說
我原本有賺
變成付四十萬
這件事是真的
我今年賺的很像都去了
是
我這樣就叫被洗出廠了嗎
我朋友其實跟我說要穩健一點
買台積電
買一些大的金融股也好
至少他們是集資在賺錢
他們在操作
總比你自己放活存好
對
好吧
我就買一些富邦金國泰金
還有我自己存的 玉山巾
還有台積電
真的就慢慢的起來了
當然我自己本業也很努力
有在賺
我自己的子彈多了
我就還會進去
一陣子就忘記教訓了
手又癢了
電話又來了
有沒有要唱
我絕不當沖我已經講過了
剛剛B-BUS還逼下去了
這更嚴肅了
好 我後來就還是有買個股
像最近
我買那個新雨航空
新雨航空
對 那一個是
很多人就跟我說
不要買那種前方在天上的
太危險了吧
就是他們的資本支出太大了
對 要買也是買那種
大家知道的龍頭骨
我後來有還要買那個華邦店
其實我大部分的各種
華邦店最近不錯喔
那是最近啊
像你說有虧損的美獎
其實我幸運航空是因為我有到
他們股東會有講話
我有發言
大家就知道我是套住的
這是險性的
像華邦店我套住
你黃星魚買多少
我買
他之前那個上櫃的時候
我就買了
他有一度衝到40幾 無幾
我想說我也有做
我要支持我就買下去
後來它就轉彎了變30幾
然後一直到20幾
不就是因為你買了
對啊 我全世界都會覺得
自己被鎖定了
我也覺得我被鎖定了
我就有一隻一路貪進去
因為我愛做他們飛機
我自己有一個理論是
我只要用蘋果
我就會去買美股的蘋果
他們的股票
我買我開課特斯拉
我也買特斯拉
是
我覺得我自己是當個小股東
我用他們我有花錢
所以他們有賺再分我血血
對
我等於是沾著他們沾光
所以新宇航空從四五十
買到現在二十幾
對 一路買到現在二三二四
二三二四
往下來 我是不會慌了
因為我知道
我現在賣掉等於是任賠了
對
我不賣掉的話 我就想說
他們的董事長或他們的
整個團隊經營得好嗎
我常常出國我都做他們的線
所以我覺得我還是有在付出
他們人也對我不錯
今年其實航空股是賺錢的
對
賺滿多的
像華航 年中獎金
平均大概花七個月的全新
七個月很多
聽說他們連菜鳥進來
如果月薪4萬塊
一年的年中獎金都340萬
因為現在機票很貴
然後油價便宜
所以他們都是這樣會賺
而且課運跟課運都很好
可是為什麼他股價不好
就是剛剛說的
整個市場的資金不在那邊
沒有雨露金債
除非就是說
突然政策有個開放
什麼開放光光
或是開放什麼好線
有利多
然後可能長一兩天
可是像姐說的
資金不在那邊
但我資金在那邊
那這樣有的難度
妳又不咒藥
對我來說很重要
那是我自己
香蕉控股裡面的大多數
太棒了
那我在那邊
我至少也不用一直無腦
可是妳有聽說
不要跟股票談戀愛嗎
可是還是談了
我覺得有時候
談戀愛心情好過
對
香蕉現在都買龍頭股
現在買比較多
像那個每股的7巨頭
大部分都有買一些些
就像自己有用到的就買
那你錢不少耶
這樣子應該是說
我們每個都有買一些些
它疊的時候
我看那個虧損不會那麼多
是因為都分散掉了
對 其實總虧損是多的
但我就是
我主業會更激勵我自己
是
我只要不認賠
你投資股票到現在是賠還是賺
賺 大概38
那不錯
可是很多人
我身邊也有朋友
是只放那個ETF0050
對
對 他還是比我多很多很多
所以主動操作
我自己又不熟 又不做功課
又很無腦
所以有賺已經算是幸福的了
講實在話
買ETF現在是當然很好的選擇
不過因為沒有碰過
股市的崩盤跟大跌
你剛才看ETF也變這樣
對
因為現在他說0050裡頭
其實有63%是投台積電
那台積電好他就很好
所以現在你會發現
其實你身邊多了好多股神
像我去上節目
我發現
我是財經專家對不對
應該我發言
我發現那些藝人都強得比我發言
因為每個人都股票操作好厲害
大家正活潑
對
我一面上我他要節省
電話
好 那麼這個
聽說惠珠是
賣房子來買股票
也不是
因為我其實本來
我有在2021年
那時候我覺得股市在高點
所以我就想要撤出一些資金到房地產
我就去買了一個預收屋
然後去年那個預收屋又要交屋了
那本來是說可以帶三層
那你知道其實現在政府在打房
所以有現代領
所以你現在貸款帶不出來
那我本來是已經交了三層了
那他我現在還在去找另外的三層來
來交屋
對我來講是很沉重的負擔
所以我只好忍痛把它賣掉
那剛好又有人要買我房子
所以我就少賺一點
賺一點點就賣掉了
但是賣掉
現在房地產能賺也不錯
對 而且最重要是要賣得掉
所以我那時候就是有
大概賺500萬我就賣掉
一接500
總價很高
所以也沒有賺很多
有
500很高
但是我賣了
心裡有痛起來
對
剛剛被這大哥撫慰了心理
現在要被
咻咻的
沒有 我在幫政府賺錢
電力救薪
好
我幫政府賺錢
因為我賣了
我賺500萬
可是我交給政府
165萬的水
35%
35% 因為我持有
預測物車有34年
所以我是幫政府賺錢
但是我跟你說
其實後來
這裡是為什麼說明說
為什麼股市會好
因為現在打房
所以所有資金
也沒什麼地方去處
我拿到的那些錢
我投入股市
我買了台積電
買了台達電
買了紅海 買了光寶科
都買這些最好的公司
結果我在很短的時間
我賺的錢都超過我那股房
房地產賺的錢
而且又不用繳稅
資本利得不用繳稅
是
老天爺
聽說背
不過這整個大盤
就是說我們也都要科學
也都要選學
來請教一下義化
你怎麼看今年的股市
因為我們在看就是
民主五年
2026民主五年
它是火很旺的時候
所以AI它熟火
它快速疊帶的東西它都熟火
它勢必會瘋狂地往上飆
可是火有一個特性
就像我們在看
銀火網會那個火
它會忽然串上去
忽然消下來
這樣串上去消下來
所以如果說你的資金不夠雄厚
不要再去追高
但是你可以就是
在中間我覺得
部分的資金進去
錢是一定要賺的
但是不要過於貪心
對
像我有客戶就是他
因為他真的去年有賺到
有賺到
然後包括
因為我也是股市小白
然後就像慧珠姐剛剛講的
就是我是傻傻地跟著買
ETF就是人家賺我就跟著賺
因為我們就是超功課
就是以前不懂的
就看誰功課好
就會超他的筆記
應該錯不了太多
照著做
對
然後所以他說他
想要把房子再去套
套錢出來再去投進去
可是我就覺得說
千萬不要做這種事情
你手頭現金不夠
你去借房貸
雖然說他是有利差的
借房貸出來去投股市
你會以為說
如果都照這樣子
光那個利差
你就可以賺很大一筆
因為房貸貸出來就幾千萬
可是你有沒有想過
那個掉下去的時候
你撐不撐得住
因為我覺得投資
是一件很違反人性的事情
他高的時候你會貪
他低的時候你會怕
除非你可以克服自己的人性
不然去做這樣的投資
其實不管任何人都是很危險
有時候就是說
每天你單精受怕
他探一時
你就會覺得很沒用
對不對
精神上備受折磨
裡面不是已經賺40萬的開心程度
遠不及虧40萬的恐懼程度
對
虧40萬很痛
很痛
對
其實賺40萬
隔天又跌回來
還有賺32萬
可是那8萬會覺得損失了
有人會這麼想
那你當時虧了的時候
心裡有多痛
心非常非常痛
尤其這次川普
那個失約下去的時候
我照面其實是負200多
太多了
我又覺得我以前打拚的都沒了
我後來有
就像是姐妳講的
我自己有轉念
這200多我就當作認了
可是我沒有真的賣掉認
我是當作我未來這五年
我一定要賺到200多萬
來補這個動
對 我就當作
這件事沒事
那就是動力
我覺得如果說可以變成動力
就好